et on est avec nous sandrine fanny
sandrine merci d'être avec nous ce soir
on parle de harcèlement et le
harcèlement c'est pas seulement des
petites insultes et pas seulement des
vannes ça peut être extrêmement grave
vous êtes la mère de christopher un
jeune homme de 16 ans qui s'est donné la
mort en avril 2017
suite au harcèlement qu'il a subie au
sein de son école alors déjà est-ce que
vous pouvez nous raconter
quel type de harcèlement subi c'est
christopher alors christopher subi c'est
du harcèlement renferme balle peut-être
du harcèlement physique aussi donc
christopher c'était un élève n'est pas
un jeune garçon très joyeux
perfectionniste il adorait le cheval on
le traitait de [ __ ] parce que justement
il faisait du cheval
c'était des insultes tu es gros tu es [ __ ]
parce que tu fais du cheval tu es nul tu
es une sous merde
il voulait devenir maréchal ferrant oui
il voulait ouvrir une écurie avec son
frère owen killian qui est palefrenier
signé donc il voulait ouvrir tous les
deux il est au quotidien donc habilités
bousculer menacée est-ce que vous avez
remarqué quelque chose à la maison ou
pas du tout il avait 16 ans voilà et il
a eu ses il avait une 16 ans donc le 22
février à la maison non c'était un
enfant qu'il était comme tous les
enfants mais par contre avait un très
fort caractère d'accord donc à la maison
il avait un caractère très fort oui ils
vous avez quatre enfants voilà on a
quatre enfants
on n'a qu'un lave et donc de ses coudes
au frère une soeur il avait oui voilà
c'est ça me de un peu plus âgé
blanche marie une quête petit et qui
était plus petit que lui alors donc à la
maison et dames un caractère très fort
et vous avez découvert comment ce qui se
passe à l'école c'était il était
différent à l'école de ce qu'il était à
la maison malaman en fait dont il ya une
des sept christopher et puis à après sur
les réseaux sociaux on a commencé à
avoir une petite jeune qui disait que
christopher était h24 tout seul qui
rougissait des oreilles parce que comme
on l'interrogeait et après je suis tombé
sur des messages archivés
d'accord vous avez été vous est vraiment
et le fil des événements et jusqu'au sur
ces réseaux sociaux
vous avez découvert des flots d'injures
total l'ordinateur portable de votre
fils ils ont écrasé ils ont détruit
complètement et l'a dit stop il en a eu
marre
au collège il se faisait bousculer on
les traitait wii 2 balls pas tous les
noms
alors est ce que une personne du collège
les enseignants ou encore la directrice
du collège vous a signalé qu'il y avait
un problème avec votre fils ou avec les
autres élèves
est-ce qu'ils ont senti qu'il y avait
quelque chose que il est harcelé ou pas
du tout nombre
christopher a été harcelé pendant quatre
ans depuis la sixième d'après tous les
témoignages qu'on a pu avoir
on a eu différentes réunions de
professeurs et personne ne nous a jamais
rien dit on puisse christopher était un
très bon élève il avait entre 14 et 16
de moyenne depuis la sixième il est
revenue oui à la maison avec un bleu
mais nous a dit qu'il s'était cognée
contre une table avec une manche
arrachée mais parce que voilà j'étais
dans l'art dans le rang de la cantine et
puis on s'est bousculé et et et voilà ma
manche s'est arrachée et en fait comment
nous on n'a rien rien vu venir ou alors
certains professeurs vous dit certains
professeurs est au courant mais n'ont
rien dit les équipes éducatives sont
dans le déni les établissements ont peur
de la mauvaise réputation on a souvent
parlé
ces notes qui sont donnés aux
établissements et qui font que
parfois ils font passer des choses sous
silence pour avoir une bonne exactement
ça c'est incroyable la christopher pour
certains professeurs ils étaient au
courant puisque un jour il était
champion départemental de saut à cheval
donc il a fait visionner une de ses
vidéos et ouvertement on l'a traité de
[ __ ] parce qu'il faisait du cheval
christopher à la sortie d'un cours a dit
à deux trois copains toute façon vous
aurez tous votre projet des collèges
parce que je me suiciderai alors
justement il
il a fait un slap avant de commettre
l'acte irréparable qu'il a commis voilà
donne est venu nous dire que j'ai vu un
snap non le savais pas et donc c'était
une photo de christopher en faisant un
doigt d'honneur
et là je me permettre de lire à l'egypte
ou où c'était écrit à tous ceux qui
m'ont fait chi shao vous ne me reverrez
plus et c'était quelques heures avant
son décès c'est vous qui avez découvert
christopher non c'est montaigne notre
grande de 21 ans qui revenait du travail
elle craint travail dans une
restauration rapide
elle a vu de la lumière et elle s'est
mise à hurler donc son frère
kylie ann est descendu nous sommes
arrivés au même moment et montanes a
appelé les gendarmes
enfin le samu d'abord les gendarmes et
tout et j'ai attrapé christopher dans
les bras et ses crises et kilian qui est
christophe histoire incroyable juste
j'ai une question à vous poser son lit
vous en voulez à qui aujourd'hui est ce
que vous en voulez à quelqu'un ce que
vous en voulez aux gens qui ont harcelé
votre fils à l'éducation nationale aux
cô professeur la directrice du du lycée
alors déjà nous
on s'en veut aussi pas avoir vu bien sûr
voilà on est très en colère
effectivement contre les jeunes qui vont
harceler christophers puisqu'ils ont
continué aussi sur d'autres d'autres
élèves
on en veut effectivement au directeur du
collège qui nous a reçus dans son bureau
qui nous a dit que christopher septembre
octobre novembre était très compliqué
pour christopher qui avait eu un
mouvement et vous a reçu avant après le
décès de christophe d'accord après le
décès de christophe voilà vous dire que
voilà
alors c'était octobre novembre décembre
que pour que sa force était compliqué
que nous il y avait eu un manquement au
niveau du corps professoral
donc il était au courant christopher en
avait parlé beaucoup d'élèves sont venus
nous voir en épiant messages privés ou
voilà ils nous ont expliqué tout ce qui
s'est passé et donc après donc il ya une
jeune fille chiara qui a été harcelé
aussi pendant les longs mois au même
collège
voilà et quand elle a entendu le prêtre
et le directeur pendant la minute de
silence dire qu'il fallait pas chercher
à savoir pourquoi christopher a fait ça
elle était très en colère et donc du
coup elle a décidé elle a dit à sa maman
tu vas voir la maman de christopher faut
qu'on fasse quelque chose parce que
sinon je retourne pas au collège
vous avez créé l'association des
relations à la main l'association marcel
mans et là on a réussi à libérer la
parole de beaucoup de jeunes dont
beaucoup dans ce
est-ce que sandrine vous avez vous avez
rencontré les lits les jeunes hommes
pour harceler votre fils ou les deux les
ou non non ce n'est pas ça il ya une
maman qu'on voit régulièrement moi à
part monteyne nos grandes ailes et sait
exactement qui c'est votre compte voilà
notre notre fille elle s'appelle
montaigne à votre grande film est donc l
est les connaître puisque dans cette
halle a souhaité aller les voir elle est
allée les voir
non c'est qu'elle travaille dans elle
travaillait dans une restauration rapide
et ses jeunes pour harceler christopher
venait avec un grand sourire
donc elle est à démissionner parce
qu'elle a pu supporter le regard
mon mari a démissionné aussi puisqu'il
était chauffeur de car et transportait
ces jeunes
moi je suis pas capable de les
reconnaître de toute façon alors on dit
beaucoup de choses on dit que je comme
vous que j'ai eus
enfin que j'ai harcelé aussi certains
jeunes mais je suis pas capable de les
reconnaître
il ya juste une maman que je sais mais
sinon non
alors vous avez fait appel à sylvie
cavaloc le gall qui est avocate au
barreau de rennes
spécialiste du droit de la famille du
droit pénal général pourquoi qu'est-ce
que vous l'avez demandé
mais en fait on a déposé plainte
un croquis au départ contre x parce
qu'il fallait protéger les jeunes qui
avait harcelé christopher et contre
l'établissement prénom alors ben non
puisque là en fait on a commencé à
porter plainte contre x
et il n'y a pas eu de suite on a eu un
sens suit donc on n'a pas eu le temps
encore 2
alors on est le dossier m cavaloc alors
ensuite au classement sans suite
effectivement dont vient par les cendres
il fallait le dossier
c'est ce classement sans fil peut être
contesté on peut saisir à nouveau le
doyen des juges d'instruction ça c'est
un recours possible
quand faut-il avoir le le dossier donc
on a fait la demande dès qu'on a été
informé du classement sans suite
au mois de mai 2018 et le dossier je
l'attends encore d'accord
donc on a pu avoir accès très récemment
donc mercredi dernier on a pu j'ai pu
consulter le dossier savoir un petit peu
ce qui avait été dit donc il y aura un
recours ne vais pas pouvoir bien sûr
évoqué ceux qui figurent dans ce dossier
mais certainement il y aura donc une
contestation de ce classement sans suite
ce qui est possible en saisissant le
doyen des juges mais alors sandrine est
ce que les élèves qui ont harcelé votre
fils
ils sont toujours dans le dans cet
établissement ils sont plus dans
l'établissement risque alors oui c'est
celle des tensions au lycée maintenant
voilà maintenant ils sont lisses et donc
mais ils sont restés était resté après
le décès de christopher et qu'est ce
qu'il a dit le directeur de l'école que
je crois je suis la question vous dit
quoi après au départ donc il dit nous a
dit voilà il y avait un manquement au
niveau du corps ne ment moral
mais voilà c'est christopher s'était
fait harceler sur les réseaux sociaux
mais en aucun cas dans son collège ce
qui était complètement faux puisque nous
quand on l'a eu dans dans son bureau il
nous avait dit qu'effectivement il avait
entendu certaines choses je suis content
ça m'a l'air après voilà c'est un
établissement privé faut cacher la
vérité on a été on nous a quand même les
services sociaux sur par rapport à notre
dernière qui a voulu donc qui était
aussi dans ce même collège
donc ma fille me demandait tous les
jours pendant deux mois si elle n'avait
pas été obligée de partir de la maison
parce qu'à 20 voilà on a essayé de nous
faire taire alors là quand vous entendez
ce témoignage autour de la table la
question qu'on me pose l'école est elle
responsable l'a alors karim zéribi vous
dites quoi là bas quand j'entends moi
cette maman dévasté frappés par ce drame
de queue on se dit à l'évidence ce que
nous a dit que son gamin a vécu quatre
ans de harcèlement
4en douar seulement jeudi en quatre ans
comment se fait tiquer pas un adulte qui
fut mon nom est détectée décelé je
dirais que les brimades les humiliations
quasi quotidiennes et certainement de
cul pour que ce gamin canaris sans plus
tarder à ça se faisait en cas ça se
faisait en classe de quessy moi je
considère pour tous les problèmes de
société dont celui là qui est un
problème profond sérieux qui dévasté des
familles si on ne regarde pas les
problèmes en face on ne peut pas les
traiter
donc on peut pas mettre le couvercle
quelques écoles que ce soit un moment
donné on peut pas imaginer que notre
école aura une bonne image si on ne
parle pas des problèmes sur les
problèmes il faut en parler mais il faut
les affronter
sinon on ne trouve pas de solution et
c'est vrai que dans l'éducation
nationale bon nombre de sujets ont été
tabou jusqu'à présent dans le
harcèlement
il faut qu'on fasse sauter ce tabou et
qu'on en parle et qu'on mobilise les
parents les éducateurs même périscolaire
ne passe que cela aussi peuvent détecter
les adultes il faut que cette chaîne
d'adultes travaillent ensemble pour
déceler un moment donné des
comportements qui ne sont pas normales
pour un gamin qui est aussi brillant de
qui qui au demeurant n'a pas de problème
on fait nos enfants il fait du il fait
du cheval il est brillant à l'école je
veux dire mon année vous avez passé un
petit madame un moment donné que votre
fils christopher n'avais rien senti
passer ses journées à au centre équestre
avec son frère enfin quand il est avec
vous ils étaient heureux
au delà de détecter carré dit il a
confirmé les yeux oui pas possible c'est
trop cheap sûr je suis sûr tu as raison
qu'il faut détecter qui ont fermé les
yeux c'est inadmissible chez les yeux
puisque d'autres élèves ont été harcelés
après il ya eu harcèlement sexuel il ya
eu dans le même collège dans le même
collège
il y avait des scarifications
nous on en voit plein dans notre
association la mare seulement c'est bien
pour ça qu'on on veut libérer la parole
des jeunes parce qu'il faut qu'ils
arrivent à parler à quelqu'un de courant
en confiance et l'association s'est fait
avec les jeunes et là on voit tous les
témoignages sont à de jeunes et de
parents qui cherchent à une question de
l'avocat thierry lemaître
ça veut dire que les gamins qui ont été
des harceleurs là en l'occurrence sont
aujourd'hui dans l'impunité totale dans
l'impunité c'est bien alors la
difficulté c'est qu'on a un classement
sans suite parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'élément suffisant de preuves parce que
c'était une classe dans lequel étaient
étaient christopher qui avaient un mode
de fonctionnement comme ça c'était un
peu ce qui a été retenu
on avait des enfants qui s'insultent est
quotidiennement régulièrement à travers
les réseaux sociaux dans là tout le
monde sauf donc s'être ensuite ça
devient normal s'est banalisé donc on va
dire à partir du moment où ils
s'insultent et que chacun accepte et que
christopher a même été décrit comme
étant gardons le sourire c'est que
manifestement ça ne l'affectait pas ça
n'est pas considéré comme du harcèlement
donc le voilà la difficulté ce que je
voulais dire parce qu'au travers du
combat aujourd'hui que mène sandrine
fallait c'est la prévention
bien sûr qu'elle est indispensable au
sein des établissements scolaires et
auprès des enfants pour qu'ils
comprennent effectivement ce que peut
engendrer sur et quel est l'impact des
propos qui peuvent tenir même s'ils
n'ont pas
sentiment de la volonté de faire du mal
c'est que cette parole c'est cette
prévention doit entraîner permettre aux
enfants de pouvoir s'exprimer de se
libérer il y a beaucoup de lieux où ils
peuvent s'exprimer au travers du trentin
effectivement le numéro auprès
d'organisations ou d'associations parce
que il est difficile pour des enfants de
s'exprimer au sein de leur famille
difficile de s'exprimer même auprès de
leurs propres amis très proches parce
que ils ont la crainte est vrai que ces
secondes mais le gros problème c'est
qu'il s'en aille mais